la parole est maintenant monsieur
olivier faure président du groupe
nouvelle gauche à l'assemblée nationale
monsieur président du congrès mais le
président du sénat mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues le
président emmanuel macron a finalement
choisi pour s'exprimer la forme la plus
commode
cette forme c'est celle du congrès ou
sitôt achevé son discours il s'échappe
le président parle mais je ne vais pas
pas il n'est donc plus parmi nous mais
il y à issy suffisamment de
représentants pour m'entendre c'est à
lui que je veux m'adresser désormais
monsieur le président donc dans un monde
où tout va si vite et où les exigences
citoyennes sont si grandes
la puissance tient moins à la force
qu'on impose cas l'adhésion que l'on
suscite
vous avez au moins 2 mais que au mois de
juin à qui la légitimité du pouvoir mais
vous n'avez pas encore gagné l'adhésion
des français
cela reste devant vous créé cette
adhésion car en une phrase cette phrase
elle n'est pas de moi elle et de pierre
mendès france
gouverner c'est choisir si difficile que
soient les choix et monsieur le
président c'est bien le problème vous
concernant vous avez décidé d'occuper le
terrain par la verticale vous posez
l'autorité oui mais l'homme de décision
mais si on sort du chan si l'on prend le
contrechamp l'image n'est plus aussi net
pour ne pas dire qu'elle est parfois
floue
ce flou se résume en une tournon de
langage s'est tenue de cette tournure
cette fois ci elle est de vous elle
tient en trois mots en même temps mais
monsieur le président choisir ce n'est
pas à bruxelles prenez le bateau de rire
ou réfugiés et en même temps et j'estime
attiser les associations et accepter
qu'un dignité s'installe aux abords de
calais choisir ce n'est pas écrire que
l'état d'urgence n'a pas vocation à
durer
et en même temps vouloir aggraver des
mesures d'exception dans le marbre du
droit commun choisir je vais pas
prétendre moraliser la vie publique et
en même temps oubliez vos engagements en
matière d'incompatibilité entre mandat
parlementaire et activités de conseil ou
sur le casier judiciaire vierge
choisir ce n'est pas affirmer protéger
le monde du travail et en même temps
revenir sur le conte pénibilité
faciliter les licenciements ou plafonner
les indemnités pour licenciement abusif
choisir ce n'est pas affiché la volonté
d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
classes populaires et des classes
moyennes et en même temps augmenter la
csg pour les retraités pour mieux
baisser l'impôt sur la fortune des
actionnaires choisir ce n'est pas
affirmer la volonté d'en finir avec la
taxe d'habitation qui est un impôt
injuste et en même temps prévoir de le
faire supporter aux collectivités
locales avec pour résultat
l'insupportable inégalités territoriales
choisir ce n'est pas crier au monde que
nous devons rendre notre planète
great games et en même temps envisagé de
revenir sur l'interdiction des nique des
néonicotinoïdes il n'y a finalement
qu'un en même temps que je regrette
on ne peut réformer la puissance
publique sans en même temps évoquée la
toute puissance des intérêts privés
monsieur le président conduire une
politique et de gauche et de droite
c'est conduire une politique sans choix
nous partageons ensemble en cette
assemblée le même amour de la france
la même envie que notre pays retrouve sa
grandeur le même souci de servir au
mieux nos concitoyens mais en même temps
mélanger l'eau froide et l'eau chaude
cela n'a jamais donné que de l'eau tiède
l'adhésion viendra donc de vos choix
votre politique sera t-elle est synonyme
de progrès pour tous pour construire
l'avenir
il ne suffit pas de valoriser ceux qui
ont ce camp sont déjà les plus
entreprenants tout en laissant penser
que d'autres ne sont rien vous devez
reconnaître et accompagner tous les
talents tous les potentiels combattre le
gâchis humain que représente le chômage
les discriminations ou décrochage
scolaire chacun peur de sa contribution
à la construction de notre pays
c'est cela la promesse républicaine
celle d'une république généreuse qui
tend la main à tous ces enfants les
réformes
vous ne pouvez les réussir seul à chaque
fois que le nouveau pouvoir issu les
urnes au à penser que sa légitimité
était suffisante pour décider et bien
celles ci ont échoué parce que votre
pouvoir est aujourd'hui absolue vous
devez vous en méfiez absolument le
tempérer le modéré même le partagez vous
le devez au pays et vous le devez en
fait à vous même
méfiez vous de la victoire monsieur le
président elle est parfois mauvaise
conseillère
nous avons vu la semaine dernière à
l'assemblée nous l'avons vu ce n'était
pas un bon signal il faut toujours
respecter le droit de l'opposition
méfiez vous de l'histoire monsieur le
président elle peut conduire un certain
nombrilisme là où il faudrait au
contraire renouvelé notre démocratie
écoutez concertée respecter le temps
nécessaire aux délibérations
parlementaires
sollicité à société civile ce n'est pas
un sésame pour être élu mais une source
à laquelle puiser les solutions pour
demain
comme le disait michel rocard ce qui est
accepté à infiniment plus de force que
ce qui est imposé
tous les débats n'ont pas été tranchées
avec votre élection
il reste ouvert et demande donc être
instruits méfiez vous de vous même
monsieur le président parce que
l'intuition qui vous a conduit au
pouvoir par la grâce de l'épuisement des
partis de gouvernement
c'est le solde une période confondent
pas pour autant une nouvelle
avoir réuni des femmes et des hommes des
deux rives ne réinvente pas forcément
les clivages politiques
méfiez vous de vous même enfin monsieur
le président parce que votre jeunesse ne
vous met pas à l'abri de vous tromper
d'époque vouloir conduire aujourd'hui à
la hussarde des réformes parfois
empruntés aux siècles passés sans
s'interroger sur les drames qu'elles ont
généré serait un contresens la qualité
de vos réformes sociales dépendra donc
du partage leur construction avec les
représentants des salariés dont le
travail est la source même de toutes les
richesses
la réussite de la mobilisation du pays
dépendra de votre soutien à l'initiative
des citoyens des associations des ong
des entrepreneurs
la france doit rompre avec la tentation
colbertiste si bien représenté par la
citadelle de bercy alors ferez vous
confiance d'abord aux françaises et aux
français
ferez vous confiance aux territoires aux
élus locaux aux collectivités qu'il
dirige dans une république décentralisée
la nation ne peut réussir sans
travailler main dans la main avec ses
villes et ses communes
ces départements ces régions et de ce
point de vue réduire les dotations aux
collectivités c'est mal prendre le
chemin de la confiance et du partenariat
dont la france a besoin
monsieur monsieur le président dans les
écoles ma circonscription les enfants
vous appelle désormais jupiter c'est à
la fois louangeurs et moqueur comme vous
le voyez nos enfants ont des lettres et
du bon sens
il semble bien que le chemin que vous
prenez n'est pas celui forcément des
risques équilibrés du pouvoir d'une
citoyenneté active et d'une délibération
ouverte et partager et ce alors même que
le passé a déjà montré l'impasse du
pouvoir personnel et alors que votre
marche esquissait un avenir fondé sur la
rénovation de la vie politique par la
valorisation de la diversité du
pluralisme et de l'engagement de chacun
j'achève mon propos monsieur le
président le premier ministre mes chers
collègues chaque fois que vos décisions
conduiront la france sur les chemins du
progrès partagé
nous serons là pour approfondir et
consolider mais à chaque fois comme
décisions auront pour effet d'accroître
les inégalités de précariser les plus
désarmé d'affaiblir les services publics
qui sont le patrimoine de ceux qui n'ont
rien mais qui ne sont pas rien vous
rencontrerez notre ferme opposition
vous vous êtes engagé à faire entrer la
politique dans une nouvelle ère et la
france dans un nouveau monde
nous vous jugeront donc sur vos actes et
sur vos actes uniquement ce sera notre
contribution à la rénovation tant
attendu il en soit nouveau monde
vous le savez désormais il y aura aussi
une nouvelle gauche
merci merci monsieur
[Applaudissements]